hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live vor gut einer Stunde hat die
Räumung in lützerath begonnen dort haben
Aktivisten den kleinen Ort am Rande des
Tagebaus Garzweiler in
Nordrhein-Westfalen besetzt wollen nicht
dass dort geräumt und künftig Kohle
abgebaut wird die Polizei ist heute mit
einem Großaufgebot dort und
Einsatzkräfte sind vor Ort und es kam
auch schon zur ersten
Auseinandersetzungen zwischen
Einsatzkräften und Demonstrierenden auf
der anderen Seite es ist kurz nach
morgen braun und tausende Polizisten
kommen gehen los auf das Gelände und es
kommt dann auch im weiteren Verlauf des
Morgens zu ersten Auseinandersetzung
zwischen der Polizei und den Aktivisten
AktivistInnen nach Angaben der Polizei
sollen Steine und Pyrotechnik in
Richtung der Einsatzkräfte geworfen
worden sein und auch
Molotow-Cocktails sein dem nach
eingesetzt worden haben wir bei Twitter
gelesen
immer Aktivisten Aktivistin gegen
Polizei Klimaschutz gegen Kompromiss mit
kohlekonzern es geht da um mehr als nur
irgendeinen kleinen Ort in
Nordrhein-Westfalen die Räumung in
lützerath das ist heute live unser Thema
und wir können direkt sprechen mit
unserem Reporter vor Ort schon den
ganzen Morgen im Einsatz Ralf Goldmann
hallo guten Morgen wie ist denn die Lage
aktuell
guten Morgen also inzwischen muss man
sagen dass sich die Lage tatsächlich ein
bisschen beruhigt hat also wir haben die
Bilder gesehen heute morgen kurz vor 9
Uhr da kamen hier Polizei hat Einheiten
von mehreren Seiten an diesen Ort heran
und haben hier Sitzblockaden entfernt
haben Menschenketten durchbrochen das
sah ein bisschen wild aus natürlich
haben die gewissen versucht dagegen zu
halten dann sind aber die Polizisten
hier tatsächlich in diesen Weiler
gelangt man kann das hier auch
vielleicht hinter mir sehen überall
vereinzelt stehen hier Behälter
Polizisten auch mit Schutzschilden und
sie bewachen sozusagen kontrollieren
jetzt hier so ein bisschen die Lage wir
haben auch gesehen dass einzelne
Aktivisten freiwillig ihre Zelte
verlassen haben es gab hier vernünftige
Dialoge zwischen Polizei und Aktivisten
die sind dann auch inzwischen schon raus
es gibt draußen ähm einen Kessel da sind
ungefähr weiß ich nicht 50 60
Demonstranten protestierende
eingekesselt worden man versucht jetzt
in den Schacht zu halten damit hier eben
nicht noch mehr passiert es sitzen aber
auch viele in den Bäumen oder hier oben
wenn der Kollege dann noch mal einmal
rüber schwenken kann da liegt oben einer
noch in der Hängematte neben diesem
monoport diese Menschen sind natürlich
schwierig rauszukriegen und man will
natürlich versuchen dass das alles ohne
Verletzungen hier abgeht aber wie gesagt
im Moment ist die Lage relativ ruhig das
wird sich aber natürlich ändern wenn
versucht wird die Leute aus den
Baumhäusern rauszuholen weil die
Baumhäuser müssen natürlich alle erstmal
von Menschen befreit werden bis man sie
abreißen kann und dann auch die Bäume
fällen kann und das wird sicherlich noch
eine Zeit lang dauern bis rwe-trupps
tatsächlich hier anrücken
wir schauen auch mal gerade ganz kurz
bei Twitter denn die Polizei Aachen die
für diesen Einsatz auch heute
pressemäßig verantwortlich ist die
twittert und schrieb eben auch vor zwei
Stunden die Polizei hat in den frühen
Morgenstunden damit begonnen die
Ortslage lützerath zu umstellen also das
vom umstellen die Rede von der Bereich
wird um zornt Personen im abgesperrten
Bereich haben aktuell das war vor einer
Stunde noch die Möglichkeit den Ort ohne
weitere polizeiliche Maßnahme zu
verlassen das klingt ja jetzt alles Ralf
also schon auch wir haben es auch
angesprochen nach wirklich einem
Großeinsatz ist das auch ein Thema ist
das ein Problem dass da jetzt so viele
Beamte den Bereich um Zäunen sich da
also gegenüberstehen wie ist das
einzuschätzen ist dieses Großaufgebot
nötig gewesen
ja also laut Polizei ist es natürlich
nötig um hier wirklich alle in Schacht
zu halten und vor allen Dingen auch
andere Stellen außerhalb von lützerath
zu sichern also dieses Tagebaugelände
ist ja riesengroß und man rechnet
natürlich damit dass es überall
vielleicht baggerset Bagger Besetzungen
geben wird das ist anders so Zufahrten
blockiert werden vielleicht und deswegen
haben wir heute morgen schon wir sind
seit ungefähr 6 Uhr hier viele
Polizeiwagen gesehen die hier angerückt
sind also es ist wirklich eine sehr sehr
große Übermacht ich würde mal sagen sind
vielleicht ein paar hundert Besetzer die
sich hier noch aufhalten und die Polizei
ist deutlich in der Mehrheit und man
kann das auch draußen sehen an den
Polizei Kessel der da eingerichtet
worden ist also das ist ein großer
Polizei Einsatz es ist diesmal er soll
der größte in der Geschichte
Nordrhein-Westfalens sein das scheint
aber nicht ganz so zu sein aber es ist
schon ein sehr sehr großer
Polizeieinsatz in Nordrhein-Westfalen
das muss man schon sagen ja die
Aktivistin Aktivisten im Vorfeld selbst
immer wieder zu einem friedlichen
Protest aufgerufen wie kannst du dir das
erklären du hast ja den ganzen Morgen
erlebt dass es dann trotzdem eben zu
diesen Auseinandersetzungen kommt was
passiert dann in diesen Momenten
also man muss wirklich sagen dass der
Großteil so wie ich das hier wahrnehme
dieser Menschen hier sind wirklich
friedlich sind also wir haben natürlich
das also auch vorhin gesagt in den
sozialen Netzwerken von gehört dass
Steine und Feuerwerkskörper und
molotowcocktes geflogen sind es gab ja
einen Brandgeruch in der Luft als wir
hier heute morgen gekommen sind aber das
sind tatsächlich einzelne Fälle bisher
zumindest also man muss natürlich hoffen
dass das so bleibt es gab hier vorhin
zweimal Lautsprecher Durchsagen von der
Polizei die Aktivisten wurden hier
aufgefordert friedlich das Gelände zu
verlassen einige sind wie gesagt schon
nachgekommen es bleibt zu hoffen dass
die anderen sich auch daran halten es
wird aber sicherlich und das hat die
Polizei auch am Montag schon gesagt auch
Bilder geben wie man sie vielleicht
nicht sehen will der Polizeipräsident
hat gesagt wenn man solche Bilder sieht
dann ist das immer das allerletzte
Mittel dann haben wir vorher
kommuniziert und haben die
eskalationsteams da und das da im
Prinzip dann die letzte Möglichkeit die
Menschen herauszubekommen weil die
Bagger stehen im Prinzip schon vor der
Tür vor RWE von RWE und wollen hier die
Bäume fällen wir müssen ja bis zum 28.2
gefällt sein dann endet die
rodungssaison und wenn das nicht
passiert ist dann kann der Tagebau eben
nicht fortschreiten und dass wenn man
erreichen rWE hat heute morgen auch eine
Pressemitteilung noch mal herausgegeben
und gesagt die dieser lützerat dieser
Weiler muss so heißt es in der
aw-sprache bergbaulich in Anspruch
genommen werden man wolle einen
anderthalb Kilometer langen Zaun bauen
und wenn dann die Menschen irgendwann
mal raus sind aus den Baumhäusern von
den monopods und den treports dann
könnte das relativ schnell gehen dass
sie alles dem Erdboden gleichgemacht
wird das haben wir jedenfalls in den
anderen Dörfern immer da z.B hier ganz
in der Nähe auch gesehen dass das also
wirklich verdammt schnell geht ja
ich habe in den Kommentaren eine Frage
gesehen da fragte sich jemand wie
bekommt man die Menschen denn dort
überhaupt raus wie kann man sich das
vorstellen werden die weggetragen wir
haben eben erste Bilder gesehen wie
funktioniert das da aktuell
ja also wie gesagt aktuell sieht er in
der Richtung noch gar nichts ich gucke
jetzt mal um mich wir müssen da
vielleicht mal oben dahin schwenken auf
dieses monopold wurde dieser Mensch mit
diesem weißen Maleranzug sieht das sind
natürlich Strukturen das ist nicht so
einfach daran zu kommen und das wird
auch sicherlich eine der letzten
Strukturen sein die da eingerissen
werden es wird dann irgendwann wenn hier
keine Gefahr für Leib und Leben mehr
besteht große steigerfahrzeuge kommen da
wird eine klettereinheit kommen der
Polizei und dann werden diese Menschen
dort oben losgebunden und dann in einem
Korb quasi über diesen Steiger
heruntergebracht und das muss man im
Prinzip ein jedem dieser monopold oder
Tripods oder Baumhäuser so machen es ist
natürlich sehr aufwendig aber das Gerät
steht alles schon bereit und wenn hier
alles gesichert ist und keine Menschen
mehr gefährdet sind wird das auch
losgehen aber ja die Leute die in den
Häusern dann sich Verstand haben das
wissen wir nicht wir müssen noch mal
ganz kurz darüber schwenken da hinten
sind nämlich noch ein paar Häuser die
gehören auch noch zu lützerat dazu der
weiß die Polizei gar nicht ob da noch
Menschen drin sind und ob sich da
vielleicht irgendwo welche einbetoniert
haben oder woanders verschanzt haben mit
irgendwelchen Räumen also das kommt dann
nachher auch noch dazu
das wird ein langwieriges Prozedere hier
diesen Weiler von Menschen zu befreien
kurz noch deine Einschätzung zum Schluss
ich höre also raus du glaubst nicht dass
das etwas ist was mit dem heutigen Tage
also endet
auf gar keinen Fall das wird dauern das
ist halt die erste Phase dass die
Menschen aus dem Baumhäusern rauskommen
und ich gehe mal davon aus dass das
mehrere Wochen dauern wird also man muss
sich auf einen mehrwöchigen Einsatz
einstellen deshalb die Polizei und RWE
auch gesagt ja Anfang Mitte Februar
vielleicht dann kommt ja auch noch
Karneval da werden auch wieder viele
Polizisten benötigt ich habe das Gefühl
dass man da fertig sein will
sagt Ralf Goldmann Reporter für uns vor
Ort du bleibst auch noch weiter vor Ort
Ralf falls sich die Lage verändert
vielen Dank jetzt aber erstmal bis
hierhin
und wir haben aber noch Gelegenheit
jetzt im Verlauf dieser Sendung mit
unterschiedlichsten Menschen vor Ort zu
sprechen denn es ist spannend es sind
natürlich zwei Seiten die da heute
aufeinanderprallen und das ganze hat
eine lange Geschichte es waren nicht nur
klimaaktivistinnen Aktivisten die sich
im Vorfeld aber auch kritisch über
diesen großen Polizeieinsatz geäußert
haben auch darüber können wir gleich
sprechen möchte Kommentare von euch aber
auch noch hier mit reinbringen Fritz
focol bei Facebook schreibt zu unserer
Demokratie gehören Diplomatie und
Kompromisse das gilt auch für die
Menschen die protestieren und jetzt
haben wir die Möglichkeit mit dem
Polizisten der dort im Einsatz ist im
Pressesprecher der Polizei Aachen vor
Ort mit Andreas Müller zu sprechen über
seine Sicht auf diesen Einsatz mit
dieser wir haben es angesprochen enormen
Polizeipräsenz schön dass Sie bei uns
sind hallo Herr Müller
hallo
schildern Sie mir doch bitte einmal den
Morgen sie sind ja auch schon seit den
frühen Morgenstunden dort aus ihrer
Sicht wie ist die Lage aktuell und wie
war sie heute früh
ich würde sagen durch mich also ich
würde die Lage jetzt im Moment als ruhig
bezeichnen der Polizeieinsatz hat heute
morgen um halb acht etwa begonnen und
wir haben zunächst mal die Ortslage
Glitzer radier mit Polizeifahrzeugen
umschlossen danach haben wir begonnen
hier vor lützerath die Leute
anzusprechen mit Lautsprecher Durchsagen
und unsere Teams und aufgefordert die
Aussage lutzerat zu verlassen es kam im
hinteren Teil tatsächlich auch zu
vereinzelten Steine geworfen und zu
einzelnen Mall of Cocktail beworfen
sie sagen sie haben mit
Polizeifahrzeugen das Gebiet umschlossen
ist das dann aber auch eine Situation wo
das dann natürlich auch leicht ist dass
es dann eskaliert wenn man sich
eingekesselt fühlt wenn ein gekesselt
wird können Sie uns das so ein bisschen
aus der polizeiperspektive mal
beschreiben
naja ich würde mal so sagen für uns ist
das ein professionelles Vorgehen das war
vorher so geplant und wir haben ja
unsere Szenarien vorher sozusagen
durchdacht und für uns ist das alles
sozusagen nach Plan gelaufen natürlich
ist das aber für unser Gegenüber der
Termin rückt ja nun immer näher und wir
haben gesagt dass wir nach der
Bürgerveranstaltung die gestern
stattgefunden haben dass dann jederzeit
mit einer Räumung gerechnet werden muss
ist das natürlich eine emotionale
Situation und das sind eben genau die
Momente wo möglicherweise dann Steine
fliegen
jetzt gab es im Vorfeld berichtet dass
also jetzt Beamte Beamtinnen aus 14
Bundesländern für heute den Tag
zusammengezogen sind also auf jeden Fall
aus mehreren Bundesländern ist denn
ihrer Meinung nach wirklich so viel
Präsenz nötig oder ist die im Zweifel
eben bedrohlich einschüchternd das sagen
ja die kritischen Stimmen
ja die kritischen Stimmen hören wir auch
aber ich kann versichern dass aus
unserer Sicht natürlich so ein Einsatz
in der Komplexität in der Komplexität
wir haben unheimlich viele ja
Situationen wo wir Spezialeinheiten
anfordern müssen wenn man an die
höhenrettungsteams denkt und die ganzen
technischen Einheiten die hier mit lock
on zu tun haben Barrikaden das ist schon
große Aufwand aber der ist sicherlich in
der Größenordnung auch rechtfertigt wir
haben Kommentare hier bei uns im Stream
Michael Moritz Max schreibt bei Facebook
Steine und Molotow Cocktails geht gar
nicht das ist kein Spaß mehr und wir
haben noch einen Kommentar von Jana bei
Facebook die schreibt es sind keine
Aktivisten was die sich alles schon
geleistet haben ist schon kriminell also
das ist hier eine Meinung jetzt die
Frage an Sie ist das so man ist ja nicht
per se kriminell wenn man Aktivist ist
oder was geht da gerade vor sich wie
schätzen Sie diese Lage ein von dem was
da passiert
das ist sehr wichtig wirklich genau zu
differenzieren also ich stelle das so
fest wir haben hier unheimlich viele
Leute die auch wirklich friedlich
protestieren und an der Stelle sagen die
Leute die sich auf dem Boden setzen und
dann von der Polizei wegtragen lassen
solange man keine Gegenwehr leistet dann
ist das eine Protest vor mit der wir mit
der wir auf jeden Fall gut klarkommen
natürlich gibt es dann auch vereinzelte
aber das muss man ebenso differenziert
sehen vereinzelte die hier zu
Gewaltstraftaten neigen und die dann die
Polizisten mit Steine bewerfen da muss
man ganz klar sagen da ist eine Grenze
erreicht da hört auch unsere
Kommunikation auf und das sind
Straftaten die wir dann noch konsequent
verfolgen müssen aber man sollte genau
hinschicken genau hinschauen man sollte
nicht allen Menschen die sich hier in
der Auslage befinden direkten Stempel
aufdrücken
unsere Userin bei Youtube möchte von
Ihnen gerne wissen hat man in solch
einem Einsatz moralische
Gewissenskonflikte und kann die
Gegenseite gegebenenfalls doch verstehen
also jeder von uns hier dem Einsatz ist
hat sicherlich eine persönliche Meinung
hat auch eine persönliche Meinung zum
Klimaschutz und zum zum
Braunkohletagebau aber die muss man in
so einem Einsatz ausschalten und die
dafür einfach keine Rolle spielen wir
müssen ja professionell handeln und es
tun als Polizei und was ist da ihre
Taktik für dscalation denn die Lage ist
ja noch nicht beendet wär mir auch von
unserem Reporter eben gehört das ist ja
wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht mit heute
unbedingt abgeschlossen dieser Einsatz
nein wir haben uns auf einen
mehrwöchigen Einsatz eingestellt das
hängt auch tatsächlich von vielen
Faktoren ab wir werden auch erst wenn
wir in lützerath wirklich in den Häusern
drin sind sehen mit welchen
widerstandsstrukturen wir es hier zu tun
haben und welche Herausforderungen sich
da bieten aber wir haben zumindest alles
dafür getan im Vorfeld dieses Einsatzes
um den Einsatz auf kommunikative Säulen
zu stellen wir haben kommt Teams im
Einsatz das sind Beamte die nicht nur
heute sondern auch schon eine lange Zeit
Vorlauf vor diesem Einsatz hier das Jahr
über im Einsatz sind und hier im Einsatz
vermitteln sollen zwischen allen
Beteiligten und erstmal zunächst in
kommunikativen weglöse suchen
und was ist ihre Prognose ich weiß die
ist schwer wahrscheinlich anzustellen
aber was ihre Prognose wie lange wird
dieser Einsatz noch dauern
das ist wirklich überhaupt nicht
vorhersehbar das hängt wie gesagt von
sehr vielen Faktoren ab und im Moment
ist der Einsatz gerade erstmal
angelaufen ist es wenige Stunden alt wie
sich die Lage darstellt das werden wir
erst im Verlauf des Tages sehen
das sagt Andreas Müller der
Pressesprecher der Polizei in Aachen
vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung heute
sehr gerne
und es ist eben für viele natürlich dort
geht es um viel mehr ich habe es
angesprochen am Anfang der Sendung es
geht eben viel mehr als um diesen
kleinen Ort in Nordrhein-Westfalen für
viele ist das eben eine Entscheidung in
lützerath die einer
Grundsatzentscheidung gleich kommt geht
es um wirklichen Klimaschutz sagen die
ein oder um halbherzige Kompromisse das
sagen die kritischen Stimmen also worum
geht es hier eigentlich denn das ganze
hat Geschichte ich habe es angesprochen
und was da im Vorfeld passiert ist das
hat uns Josua schwarz zusammengefasst
lützerath soll der Kohle endgültig
weichen darauf einigen sich die
Bundesregierung und das Land NRW mit dem
Energiekonzern RWE im vergangenen
Oktober das bedeutet lützerath muss
bergbaulich in Anspruch genommen werden
also abgebaggert werden wir erhalten
dafür eine politische Verständigung 8
Jahre früher aus der Kohle auszusteigen
der Kohleausstieg 2030 und die Bewahrung
von fünf Dörfern vor dem drohenden
Abriss stehen der endgültigen Räumung
und dem Abriss lutzerats gegenüber ein
Deal der bei den Klima und
Umweltbewegungen überhaupt nicht gut
ankam
lützerat war längst zum Symbol für den
Kampf gegen die fossilen Energien
geworden die Hoffnung dass eine grüne
Regierung das Dorf rettet war groß es
folgte die Ernüchterung
ob die Kohle unter lützerath überhaupt
gebraucht wird ist umstritten im
gesamten Tagebau Garzweiler gibt es 280
Millionen Tonnen Braunkohle die bis 2030
abgebaggert werden soll die
Landesregierung NRW sagt dass die Kohle
aufgrund der aktuellen Energiekrise
benötigt werde eine Studie des Deutschen
Instituts für Wirtschaftsforschung kommt
zu dem Schluss Deutschlands Klimaziele
seien nicht mehr zu erreichen wenn so
viel Kohle verbrannt werden
Aktivisten sind seit Wochen manche seit
Jahren in dem Ort in Lutzerath bei uns
jetzt Diener Hamid von der Initiative
lebt hallo schönen guten Tag
hi guten Morgen Ich sehe dass sie auf
einem Dach sitzen ist das richtig
beschreiben Sie uns doch mal gerade die
aktuelle Situation wo sind sie gerade
[Musik]
vor einem Haus in Lutzerath was wir
wiederbelebt haben seit zweieinhalb
Jahren sind wir hier im Dorf und bauen
unsere eigenen Strukturen auf damit
lützerat bleibt damit die Kohle unter
lutzerat vor allem im Boden bleibt und
heute ist es so dass die Polizei das
erste Mal ins Dorf gekommen ist dass die
uns hier umstellt haben und wir haben in
den letzten Tagen leider schon viel
Gewalt von der Polizei erfahren müssen
aber gehen jetzt besonnen und ruhig
sehen wir diesen Einsatz entgegen auf
den wir uns gut vorbereitet haben weil
wir wissen dass wir bleiben muss genau
ein friedlicher Protest war geplant aber
heute und auch in den letzten Tagen ist
es eben zu Ausschreitungen gekommen
warum ist es da eskaliert
die Eskalation geht aus unserer Sicht
ganz klar von der Polizei aus ich habe
gestern mit vielen Menschen gesprochen
Freundinnen auch die geschlagen wurden
die getreten wurden die Pfefferspray
abbekommen haben dass es echt unfassbar
dass die Regierung und damit auch die
Polizei hier die Profite von RWE schützt
im Grunde ist es so
hier werden Klimakrise Klimaziele
abgerissen und wir stellen uns mit
unserem Körper mit allem was wir
letztendlich haben in den Weg der
Polizei in den Weg dieser Regierung die
anscheinend ihre eigenen Klimaziele
nicht einhalten kann die Polizei selbst
darüber hatten wir auch im ersten Teil
der Sendung schon gesprochen spricht
selbst davon dass eben Wurfgeschosse
gefunden worden sind Steine geflogen
sind selbst Molotow-Cocktails
verurteilen sie diese Gewalt gegen die
Polizei
im Grunde ist es so dass wir hier mit
verschiedensten Mitteln in Aktionen
gehen wir haben Baumhäuser besetzt wir
haben Häuser besetzt und wir machen
Sitzblockaden und so weiter und so fort
die Gewalt über die wir hier sprechen
müssen in Lutzerath ist die Gewalt die
vom Tagebau ausgeht es ist nämlich so
dass heute schon viele viele Menschen an
der Klimakrise sterben und das vor allem
im globalen Süden die Klimakrise
versteckt jede Ungerechtigkeit die wir
kennen in unserer Gesellschaft verstärkt
Rassismus verstärkt Sexismus und wir
wissen dass die Menschen die am
stärksten an den Rand gedrängt werden
unsere Gesellschaft die sind die zuerst
auch unter diesen Emissionen leiden und
deswegen sind wir hier und sprechen
weiter über diese Gewalt die
kapitalistisch ist die neokolonial ist
und die wir stoppen müssen sie sind dort
sie sind vor Ort und wollen wenn ich das
richtig verstehe auch ja eben noch
länger bleiben wie lange glauben Sie wie
lange können Sie denn lützenrath noch
halten
wir sind gerade mit 1000 Leuten hier im
Dorf und versuchen wirklich unser Bestes
um der Polizei kein Meter zu geben und
letztendlich denke ich ist es so dass
die meisten Leute in Deutschland schon
wissen dass wir aus dieser Braunkohle
vorgestern hätten aussteigen sollen
deswegen rechnen wir mit viel
Unterstützung für die kommenden Tage und
wir denken wenn wir wirklich viele sind
können wir das auch schaffen im Grunde
ist die Frage der Hoffnung eine die sich
hier viele Stellen aber alles was wir
sagen können ist wir haben das schon mal
geschafft wir erinnern uns an den hambi
wir werden uns daran dass wir fünf
weitere Dörfer am Tagebau gasweiler
schon gerettet haben und zusammen können
wir es wieder schaffen zusammen streiten
wir für Klimagerechtigkeit wir haben
hier ganz viele Kommentare in unserem
Stream die das total spannend finden
dass sie da eben jetzt schon so lange
Zeit sind Wochen teilweise Jahre und da
gibt es eine Frage die ich rausgreifen
möchte da fragt sich jemand wie wird das
finanziert wenn man mehrere Jahre dort
vor Ort ist und eben kämpft und
aktivistisch dort lebt
wir sind super dankbar dafür dass uns
seit Jahren und auch jetzt sehr viele
Spenden erreichen aber im Grunde ist es
so für die Leute die hier leben dass wir
uns einfach solidarisch organisieren
hier wird aufeinander aufgepasst das
heißt wir haben die Jahre über immer von
zum Beispiel geretteten Lebensmitteln
zusammengekocht uns gegenseitig versorgt
geschaut wer was braucht und alle
Strukturen hier selbst organisiert
aufgebaut und glauben Sie denn dass sie
die Räumung von Lutzerath dass sie die
wirklich noch verhindern können
ich glaube wir können das schaffen ich
glaube wenn wir viele sind dann können
wir die Kohle im Boden behalten und
darum geht es auch letztendlich ob die
geräumt wird oder nicht es geht darum
dass diese Kohle nicht mehr verbrannt
wird wir rasen auf Kipppunkte zu
klimapolitisch ist einfach die
Verbrennung dieser Kohle unter Mütze hat
nicht mehr haltbar
sagt Dina Hamid von der Initiative
lützerath lebt live aus lützerath von
einem Dach vielen Dank dass Sie das
möglich gemacht haben und
und schauen wir auch mal genau dorthin
um welches Gebiet es eigentlich geht
nicht jeder von uns kennt sich dann
natürlich in NRW so gut aus und wir
schauen uns an wo das ganze liegt aber
eben auch was RWE der Energiekonzern
dort vor hat weil darum geht es ja wenn
es tatsächlich zur Räumung kommen sollte
was hat also NRW ähm RWE Entschuldigung
so RWE in NRW so ist das richtig vor um
an diese Braunkohle Flöte die da unten
in der Erde Lagern zu kommen wir schauen
uns das ganze mal an also im Rheinland
etwa 60 km nordwestlich von Köln liegt
die braunen Kohle anders als die
Steinkohle ganz nah an der Oberfläche
und eben zusätzlich zum Tagebau
Garzweiler eins kam 2006 gab es zwei
hinzu in 48 Quadratkilometer darf RWE
dort Kohle abbauen und dafür eben auch
und dass er jetzt hier entscheidend auch
Dörfer abreißen sechs sind es bisher
lutzerat nun das siebte und dort wäre
haben sie ja eben schon kennengelernt
leben seit Wochen Jahren schon das Thema
Aktivistin und Aktivisten die Bewohner
die sind längst alle umgesiedelt von
lützerath das Dorf soll Weg um an diese
besonders dicken Kohle Flöte zu kommen
die liegen bis zu wir sehen es hier 210
Meter tief in der Erde also um was geht
es da Versorgungssicherheit oder um
Klimaschutz darüber wird gestritten und
wir können darüber jetzt noch mit einer
Gesprächspartnerin reden und zwar ist
jetzt bei uns Pauline Brückner von
Fridays for future hallo schön schön
dass du bei uns bist dass Sie bei uns
sind Brünner habe ich das richtig gesagt
so dann haben wir es jetzt richtig genau
also wir hatten auch eben schon einen
Beitrag gesehen haben also gelernt und
gehört dass das ganze eine lange
Geschichte hat in lutzerat und ich meine
auch dass viele von ihnen von Fridays
for future sich da ja etwas erhofft
hatten von der grünen Regierung von der
Landesregierung dass sie sich gegen die
Räumung von stemmt lange stand sich
Fridays for future ja auch irgendwo nah
mit der grünen Regierung mit der grünen
Partei
was ist passiert
die Kohle unter lützerath die darf nicht
befeuert werden wir wissen einerseits
dass wir sie nicht brauchen für die
deutsche Energieversorgung aber vor
allen Dingen dass das Verbrennen dieser
Kohle das Einhalten unserer deutschen
Klimaziele praktisch verunmöglicht und
was wir auch wissen die Emissionen die
wir hier in Deutschland ausstoßen die
bleiben nicht in Deutschland die
versucht Ursachen Leid und Schaden für
Menschen auf der ganzen Welt und
deswegen ist für uns natürlich klar dass
wir uns einer so fatalen Entscheidungen
die dazu noch auf fragwürdigen Zahlen
auf fragwürdigen Gutachten beruht in den
Weg stellt und er spielt es für uns dann
auch keine Rolle welche Partei das zu
verantworten hat und gab es aber im
Vorfeld austauscht zwischen ihnen
Freddys for future der Grünen
Landesregierung gab es da irgendeine
Kommunikation
das Lutzerath bleiben muss das ist schon
sehr lange klar und deswegen kämpfen wir
auch schon seit mehreren Jahren dafür
und haben natürlich auch alle Mittel
ausgereizt um das zu erreichen wir haben
versucht Gespräche mit den Grünen zu
führen wir waren erst diesen Montag noch
einmal im Wirtschaftsministerium bei
Mona Neubau um noch eine letzte Änderung
zu ermöglichen weil wir immer noch diese
Erwartung an die Landesregierung setzen
jetzt eine räumungsmoratorium
einzusetzen diesen Einsatz zu stoppen
und noch einmal sich die Fakten
anzuschauen und dann hoffentlich zu der
Entscheidung zu kommen dass das was
gerade passiert komplett irrational ist
komplett fatal aber wir sehen auch die
Regierung scheint momentan nicht den Mut
zu haben sich dem klimakillerkonzern RWE
in den Weg zu stellen solange das so
bleibt werden wir das eben selber machen
haben Sie denn noch Hoffnung dass es
tatsächlich dazu kommen könnte dass
lützerat nicht geräumt wird ist da
wirklich noch Hoffnung bei ihnen da
ich glaube mit Hoffnung werden wir nicht
schaffen aber zum Glück sind wir ja
nicht hilflos wir wissen dass wir zu Rad
bleiben kann wenn wir viele sind mein
Rucksack ist gepackt ich werde nach
diesem Interview in den Ort fahren ich
weiß dass morgen viele Unterstützer in
kommen werden auch von großen
Umweltverbänden prominenten am Samstag
ist eine große Demonstration vor Ort
angekündigt und wir sehen ja auch jetzt
schon wie viele Menschen sich direkt vor
Ort der Polizei mit ihren Körpern in den
Weg gestellt wenn mir eines Hoffnung
gibt dann das genau und wenn wir eben
über diese Proteste sprechen also
Aktivistin Aktivisten treffen auf
Polizei wir haben gehört dass es eben
auch zu Auseinandersetzungen schon kam
verurteilen sie das also viele verstehen
wahrscheinlich die Enttäuschung und die
Wut aber eben gewaltsame
Auseinandersetzung das ist ja dann noch
mal ein anderer part
mir macht es große Sorgen mit was für
einer Eskalation die Polizei gerade
diesen räumungseinsatz beginnt wir haben
in den letzten Tagen Bilder und Videos
gesehen wo demonstriertlich
demonstrierende Leute wahllos von der
Polizei geschlagen worden sind in
Situationen wo Tripods geräumt worden
sind wie man ja hier gerade auch im Bild
sieht die Polizei sich nicht an die
sicheren Verfahren gehalten hat sondern
daran gerüttelt hat Leute in Gefahr
gebracht hat und aktuell die Sanitäter
in das Dorfes aus dem Dorf raus führt so
dass es auch keine Versorgung für die
Menschen vor Ort direkt aus ihren
eigenen Strukturen gibt und das ist
natürlich gefährlich eine
Landesregierung die die ganze Zeit mit
einer friedlichen Räume geworfen hat die
muss dem jetzt auch nachkommen
es gibt hier eine Kommentatorin Pia
Lotta bei Youtube die wahrscheinlich das
also ihre ihre Haltung natürlich
unterstützt denn sie schreibt die 1,5
Grad Grenze einzuhalten wurde auch
gerichtlich bestätigt wir haben eine
recht auf Klimaschutz und darauf dass
die Politik andere Lösungen findet als
weiter den Kohleabbau zuzulassen
gleichzeitig ist es natürlich auch
gerichtlich bestätigt bestätigt und
rechtens dass RWE da jetzt
voranschreitet das ist auch eine
Wahrheit er wie ihr selbst sagt der
Strom aus der Kohle der muss das
russische Gas ersetzen die Aktivisten
Aktivisten sagen das Verbrennen der
Kohle halt die Erde Erwärmung weiter an
wie fühlt sich das für Sie an dass da so
zwei grundsätzlich gegensätzliche
Positionen da draußen in der Welt
gegeneinander stehen
muss zuallererst festhalten dass RWE
einfach keine vertrauenswürdige Quelle
ist wenn es darum geht wie viel Kohle
wir noch für die deutsche
Energieversorgung brauchen das müssen
unabhängige Gutachten feststellen und
nicht an Konzern der seit Jahrzehnten
Profit damit macht die Lebensgrundlagen
von uns allen zu zerstören darüber
hinaus wissen wir auch dass die Kohle
unter diesem Dorf nicht im Boden nicht
verbrannt werden darf wenn wir die
Pariser Klimaschutzziele noch einhalten
wollen und es macht natürlich große
Sorgen dass wir sehen dass die
Regierungen gerade überhaupt kein Plan
haben wie wollen sie es noch schaffen
das Deutschland kompatibel bleiben mit
dem Pariser Klimaschutzabkommen und
wieder erwarten dass dann Plan vorgelegt
wird und bis es den gibt muss diese
Räume gestoppt werden
das heißt also jetzt der ganz
kurzfristige Plan sie haben es gesagt
ihre charge ist gepackt sie gehen jetzt
los was glauben Sie wie geht das jetzt
weiter in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen
in und um Lutzerath
wir wissen dass unglaublich viele
Menschen in ganz Deutschland verstehen
was da gerade passiert das ist nicht
sein kann dass diese Kohle verbrannt
wird dass sie aus dem Boden geholt wird
aber dass sie vor allen Dingen auch
nicht verstehen wie es sein kann dass
dieser Einsatz genehmigt worden ist dass
eine grüne Landesregierung diese
Entscheidungen getroffen hat und wir
erwarten das sehr sehr viele Menschen
vor Ort sein werden sich diesem
räumungseinsatz friedlich in den Weg
stellen werden und wir am Ende dadurch
die Räumung verhindern können
sagt Pauline Brünger von Fridays for
future vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns zu
Gast waren sehr gerne
und auch danke für eure fragen
Kommentare und dass ihr dabei wart bei
ZDF heute bleibt ihr natürlich immer
direkt live aktuell informiert wie es
jetzt weitergeht in und um lützerath und
wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal bis
dahin tschüss
[Musik]